now that we're in 2020 truly wireless
earbuds like apples ear pods air pods
Pro and galaxy buds plus have started to
get extremely popular because more and
more smartphone brands are ditching the
headphone jack like samsung's galaxy s
20 for example and while we love these
new ear buds and I've made some very
in-depth comparison videos between them
there's one major problem with them you
can't connect them to devices that don't
have bluetooth like in-flight
entertainment systems on airplanes
gaming consoles like the PlayStation 4
gym equipment some desktop PCs or any
other device that lacks bluetooth and
that really sucks when you're spending
between a hundred to two hundred fifty
dollars on a set of wireless earbuds
like the earpods pro fortunately this
little device not only fixes the issue
but it also does the reverse by allowing
you to connect wired earphones to
smartphones and devices without a
headphone jack this is a two-in-one
Bluetooth 5 transmitter / receiver
that's $33 on Amazon which is cheaper
than the popular ear fly adapter this
transmitter is incredibly handy for so
many different situations when a device
that you want to connect to doesn't have
bluetooth we even saw people connected
to a record player car stereos
projectors audio recorders guitar
amplifiers high quality speakers home
theater amps legacy iPods and even TVs
using the included RCA audio cable
adapter that comes in the box while a
lot of Windows computers come with
bluetooth only the newest systems come
with Bluetooth 5 so older computers
could have lag in streaming quality
issues when connecting Bluetooth
earphones like air pods and that's where
this Bluetooth 5 transmitter comes in
handy it comes with a 3.5 millimeter
headphone jack cable so all you do is
plug it into a non bluetooth device like
this Windows PCs headphone jack switch
it to the transmitter mode or TX and
then hold the power button for three
seconds to turn it on then grab your ear
pods open up the lid and hold the
pairing button on the back to enter
pairing mode then double tap the power
button on the transmitter and they'll
automatically connect now anything you
play on that PC will stream to your
pods using the latest Bluetooth 5 spec
through this awesome transmitter it
holds about 8 hours of battery life but
it also comes with a charging cable in
the box which you can simply plug into
the USB port on your PC for endless
bluetooth streaming and if you're having
any issues with this the user manual is
very simple and easy to understand
what's also great about this device is
that you can pair two Bluetooth devices
at the same time which you can't usually
do and the capabilities of this don't
stop there just switch the mode to our X
or a receiver and now you can connect a
high-quality pair of Wired earbuds wired
headphones or any wired audio device and
then pair them to any Bluetooth device
that doesn't have a headphone jack like
your iPhone iPad pro or the new Samsung
Galaxy S 20 this is great for people who
have a really nice and expensive set of
Wired earphones that they want to
connect to their iPhone without
requiring the little dongle this is also
great for connecting your iPhone to a
car stereo that doesn't have bluetooth
so you can stream music from your iPhone
to your car speakers overall this is a
super handy device that you can buy and
toss into your bag just in case you ever
need to connect something that doesn't
have bluetooth and it's absolutely a
must if you're trying to use wireless
earbuds like air pods with your
PlayStation 4 we'll have links to this
device in the more expensive air flight
down in the description below if you're
interested you can also check out our
wireless earbuds comparison video right
over there and if you're not already
subscribed you can click that circle
right above to do so right now thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next video
[Music]